bonjour le 27 avril 2013
ma vie s'est arrêté plein de dossiers de
réunions de projets et puis rien of je
me suis couché je suis tombé dans le
coma je suis donc très très heureuse
d'être parmi vous aujourd'hui car je
n'aurais pas dû me réveiller
par chance je m'en suis sorti et j'ai à
ce moment là mis ma vie entre les mains
des médecins et de la science ils ont
soigné mon pancréas m'ont guérie et je
suis convaincu aujourd'hui que cette
guérison a été possible parce que
j'avais une confiance absolue en la
science
cette confiance ne met pas tombé dessus
du jour au lendemain mais elle s'est
forgée au contraire tout au long de ma
vie toute petite j'ai toujours voulu
comprendre le monde qui m'entoure est au
début
au début je ne pouvais pas concevoir
comment une plante pouvait se nourrir se
développer produire des fruits
simplement partir des rayons du soleil
simplement en bronzant et résister à la
sécheresse au gel aux parasites et nous
nourrir cette curiosité m'a été
transmise par mon père mon père était un
homme passionné par la nature
il m'a fait rencontrer des hommes
amoureux de la fabuleuse histoire des
plantes et des scientifiques qui m'ont
fait découvrir ce qui se cachait
derrière une feuille derrière une
cellule derrière des gènes j'ai voulu
tout voir tout comprendre et c'était une
évidence pour moi de faire des études
scientifiques et je suis diplômée en
biologie végétale moléculaire et
génétique
toutes ces science qui étudie et analyse
cette capacité extraordinaire qu'on les
plantes à pouvoir s'adapter en
permanence à leur environnement
et oui les plantes contrairement à nous
non pas de jambes elles ne peuvent pas
courir
elles doivent compter uniquement sur
elle-même pour affronter toutes les
agressions climatiques elles subissent
les agressions d
insectes des autres plantes des maladies
des milliers de stratégie dont l'homme a
cherché à tirer profit dans des domaines
aussi variés que l'alimentation
l'environnement le médical l'énergie et
c'est pas un hasard si des générations
de scientifiques ont consacré et
consacrent leur vie à l'étude des
plantes car il s'agit d'un enjeu vital
pour l'avenir de l'humanité
aujourd'hui le métier me permet
d'assouvir ma passion pour les sciences
et la nature ma passion pour cette
graine cette graine qui est un concentré
d'innovation de technologie mais avant
tout de vie dans le lit 30000 gène des
cellules de cette semence que je touche
et qui vous a été distribué se trouve la
clé pour répondre aux besoins aussi
mince soit-il de l'humanité une semence
et un futur êtres vivants nouveau qui a
été élaboré pour avoir des propriétés
utile et indispensable à l'homme un
meilleur rendement de meilleure qualité
nutritionnelle
tout ça peut paraître bien simple mais
avant d'en arriver là il a fallu des
années des années d'étude pour
comprendre le développement des plantes
leur comportement vis-à-vis de leur
environnement créé une semence
performante se fit grace et avant tout
au travail des hommes et aux outils de
connaissance qui sont toujours plus
précis et plus complexe pour vous donner
une idée de cette complexité dans ces
semences ces semences sont le résultat
d'un nombre d'innovations beaucoup plus
important que le nombre d'innovations
qui a été nécessaire à la conception
d'un airbus à trans a320 je travaille
depuis plus de 16 ans maintenant pour
l'interprofession des semences l'ogc
nice l'ogc nice rassemble l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière agricole française
depuis les entreprises qui chaque année
créent plus de 600 nouvelles variétés
que les agriculteurs spécialisés dans la
multiplication des sens les entreprises
qui les conditionnent
et les entreprises qui les distribue aux
450 à gré soit 450 mille agriculteurs
qui vont les semer l'ogc nice rassemble
dont des hommes qui ont des propriétés
des problématiques des objectifs
extrêmement variés et différents mais
tous ces hommes travaillent ensemble
afin de trouver des terrains d'entente
qui fasse en sorte que notre agriculture
françaises réussissent économiquement
mais aussi mais aussi et surtout
produisent des aliments sains en
quantité tout en respectant toujours
mieux l'environnement
mon expertise s'est construit pas à pas
chaque jour depuis 20 ans 20 ans de
passion fin tant de doutes de questions
et de débats et je ne vous cache pas que
c'est là la principale frustration que
je rencontre aujourd'hui sous la
pression de groupes activistes fondée
sur le rejet de principe et absolu de
toute forme d'intervention de l'homme
sur la nature des idées fausses se
propage depuis quelques années et ma
mission consiste à expliquer a
réexpliqué que la science est l'avenir
et pas et par un retour sur le passé des
idées reçues qui sont distillées en
permanence auprès du grand public et qui
aboutissent à des initiatives qui bloque
la recherche et l'innovation en france
nos chercheurs sont contraints de se
délocaliser à l'étranger ce qui abouti
paradoxalement à promouvoir le modèle
défendu par des entreprises des grandes
entreprises américaines
il existe aujourd'hui un décalage
incroyable entre la réalité de nos
productions agricoles et l'image que le
grand public en a aujourd'hui en tête
lors de mes nombreux échanges avec le
grand public
j'ai pu me rendre compte qu'il existait
trois grandes causes d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui autour de la semence la
première cause d'inquiétudes serait que
la biodiversité qu'utiles et s'appauvrit
d'année en année faux en 2000 les
agriculteurs français ont cultivé plus
de 3400 variétés de plantes différentes
et en 2014 c'est plus de 6500 variétés
de plantes qui ont été commercialisées
la biodiversité cultivée se développe
d'année en année en agriculture cette
biodiversité a été enrichi par l'homme à
partir des premières plantes sauvages
qu'il a domestiqué
l'aventuré a commencé au néolithique et
avec l'évolution des connaissances au
xxème siècle qui ont permis l de
réaliser des progrès qualitatifs et
quantitatifs exceptionnel l'homme a sans
cesse cherché à améliorer le potentiel
l'expression génétique des plantes
c'est un peu comme un coach sportif qui
durant toute la vie toute la carrière de
ses joueurs va s'attacher à optimiser
leurs forces et à lutter contre leurs
faiblesses
alors ceci se passe quelques fois dans
les salles de sport pour mesurer les
progrès accomplis mais il se passe avant
tout sur le terrain et le travail des
créateurs de nouvelles variétés se passe
dans les champs et il compose avec la
diversité des espèces existantes sur la
diversité de nos territoires
on a tous l'impression lorsqu'on
traverse la france qu'un champ de blé
ressemble à un autre champ de blé qu'un
champ de maïs ressemble à un autre champ
de maïs
or pour le maïs savez vous qu'il ya plus
de mille variétés de maïs différentes
qui sont cultivées en france
chaque variété n'est pas créée au hasard
mais faux répond à un besoin bien précis
à utilité bien précises reprenons
l'exemple du maïs vous avez du maïs pour
l'alimentation humaine avec du maïs pour
faire du maïs doux croquant du maïs pour
faire de la semoule du maïs pour faire
du pop corn ou bien du maïs pour
l'alimentation animale avec des qualités
nutritionnelles qui en fera un bon
fourrage ou encore de l'amidon du maïs
pour produire de l'ami donc pour faire
du bio plastiques
la deuxième grande cause d'inquiétudes
serait que les laboratoires s'accapare
s'approprie l'univers des semences en
les brevetés faut les 73 entreprises qui
créent chaque année ces 600 nouvelles
variétés mecque le résultat de leur
travail chaque année dans un système
totalement open source
leurs variétés sont directement
accessibles à tous pour en créer de
nouvelles
ce système cette spécificité repose sur
un système de protection dédiée au monde
du vivant
un chercheur qu'ils soient du domaine
public ou du domaine privé peut ainsi
accéder librement aux découvertes de ces
prédécesseurs ce système spécifique au
monde du vivant ce système de protection
permet ainsi de protéger l'innovation
sans interdire la recherche et il évite
également ce phénomène d'appropriation
du monde du vivant et il entretient
cette diversité d'entreprises
grâce à cette dynamique de recherche et
à cette diversité d'entreprises
aujourd'hui la france export qui
l'équivalent de la vente de 20 airbus
a320
je sais je me focalise on peut beaucoup
sur des airbus a300 mais j'aimerais que
l'on parle autant de ces jeunes
ingénieurs de la biologie des semences
que de ses ingénieurs en aéronautique
la troisième cause d'inquiétudes par
onze ans serait que les semenciers fonds
cultiver des plantes ogm dangereuse pour
la santé et pour l'environnement
faux mais les ogm un désastre ou un
miracle
et bien lui l'un ni l'autre
scientifiquement la question ne peut pas
se poser ainsi chaque évaluation de
nouvelles plantes transgéniques et fait
au cas par cas
cela dépend de l'espèce dans laquelle
vous allez introduire un nouveau
caractère celle cela dépend du caractère
que vous allez introduire et cela
dépendra également des conditions de
culture
concrètement une variété une plante ogm
peut avoir un bénéfice pour un
agriculteur ou peut être meilleure pour
l'environnement dans une zone de culture
donnée mais cette même plante ogm
cultivé dans une autre zone peut avoir
aucun intérêt de la même manière que
cette plante ogm utilisé dans deux avec
de mauvaises pratiques agricoles comme
n'importe quel autre culture peut avoir
des effets néfastes
alors qu'en est il exactement nous
consommons des plantes des produits
issus des aliments issus des plantes ogm
depuis 1996 depuis 1996 aucun n'est fait
négatifs pour la santé ou pour
l'environnement n'a été validé par
aucune communauté scientifique
on a recensé entre 1996 et 2009 plus de
15000 publications scientifiques
aucune technique à travers le monde n'a
jamais été autant étudié par des
scientifiques alors tout c'est toutes
ces questions posées aujourd'hui sur les
ogm pourrait l'être également sur nos
aliments sur les autres aliments mais
elle se focalise aujourd'hui seulement
sur les ogm sans doute pour des
questions politiques alors qu'elles
seront demain les réponses apportées par
la science et l'agriculture les
chercheurs aujourd'hui traque nouvelles
perspectives notamment pour faire
produire par les plantes des molécules
intérêts pharmaceutiques
savez vous que 60 % des médicaments
utilisés aujourd'hui pour lutter contre
le cancer sont produites à partir des
plantes
aujourd'hui je suis comme avant le 27
avril 2013
je suis comme vous je vis à 150%
je dois juste été mon pancréas qui ne
fonctionne plus aussi bien qu'avant en
prenant des comprimés de lipase
gastriques mais aujourd'hui c'est tu lis
pas ce n'est plus extraite du port mais
produite par des plantes aux états unis
la semence est le premier maillon de
l'agriculture c'est également un
exceptionnel vecteur d'innovation qui
apporte et apportera demain des réponses
au défi de produire plus et mieux
je comprends tout à fait que le grand
public puisse avoir peur de l'univers de
la recherche car c'est un univers assez
ferme et mal connu qui peut laisser
place à de nombreux fantasmes
par contre j'ai beaucoup plus du mal de
mal à comprendre ces marchands de peur
qui surf sur cette situation pour
promouvoir de l' angoisse et surtout en
tirer profit
l'agriculture française est un modèle
unique et performant en phase avec les
enjeux de la société
l'agriculture française est une chance
pour nous tous
je ne peux donc que vous encourager à
planter ses graines de lin qui vous ont
été données et comme disait nietzsche
tout le monde croit que le fruit
l'essentiel de l'arbre quand en réalité
c'est la graine merci